foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
characterization of anti-her2 antibodies
using Advanced flow cytometry and bli
label free detection this webinar is
part of the sixth annual event in the
drug Discovery and development virtual
event series and I'm Susie Valdez of
Labyrinth and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labroot and
sponsored by Sartorius for more
information about Sartorius go to
sartorius.com now let's get started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our live chat feature during this
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the left of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of this
presentation now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
simply click on the help desk button
located at the top of your screen within
the navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credit click on
that continuing education credits link
located in the abstract tab from the
menu at the left of your screen and
follow the process to obtain those
credits
without further Ado I now present
today's speaker Christy McBean scientist
at bioanalytics applications group as
Taurus for a complete biography of our
speakers please visit the presenter tab
from the menu at the left of your screen
Christy welcome you may now begin your
presentation
today I'll be present in this webinar
focused on the characterization of
antibodies entitled characterization of
antihatu antipodes using Advanced face
cytometry and bli label-free detection
so first on the agenda is an
introduction to the instruments that
were used to generate the data in this
webinar which were the IQ Advanced flow
cytometry platform and the octet bli
label-free detection system
I'll then outline the antibodies that
were used to exemplify this combined
workflow approach to antibody
characterization and then I will go into
a description of the assays that were
used along with some specific data
examples
so this is the iq3 advanced
photocytometry platform
one of its key features is its very high
speed at acquiring sample and this is
due to the patented air gap sampling
technology which means that the probe
can move very quickly between the wells
of a 96 or 384 well plate without the
need to flush the sample in between the
wells and so this obviously drastically
speeds up the rate of acquisition
the IQ has 15 detection channels so that
means a vast quantity of information can
be collected in a single room
the volume requirements for the IQ
system are very low and also
particularly with many of the reagent
kits so typically the required volumes
for those are about five to ten
microliters
it's also very easy to use largely due
to the inbuilt foresight software into
which you can import things such as
analysis templates from the um preset
templates in the kits and then these
will Auto populate during sampling
they'll also be comforted with a preset
compensation values so this drastically
speeds up the time to
um
for asset development and also data
analysis
and then this just shows some examples
of the kits in the iqv portfolio so
these cover a range of different disease
areas namely in immune oncology antibody
Discovery and foundational cell
functions
and this is the octet bli label-free
detection system so it's largely based
around these dip and read biosensors
which include a 2d binding surface onto
which there are specific molecules
immobilized depending on the type of
sensor and then this will allow
interactions with soluble molecules in
your assay plate to be measured
and this can be used to measure a range
of different parameters so for example
we can look at The Binding specificity
so just an indication of whether
molecules interact with each other
it can give information on binding
kinetics so um the software can generate
values such as Association and
Association rates
those associations Association rates can
then be used to generate a measure of
binding Affinity so for example KD
values
and then also the octet can be used for
example to look at um concentration
analysis so for example to
um determine the title of IGG in a
sample and this is done by measuring The
Binding rate of your sample and
comparing it to The Binding rate of a
known standard curve
and this is just a list of some of the
off-the-shelf biosensors that are
available for the octet
um so each has a different molecule
immobilized on its 2D binding surface
and means that it can be used for
different applications so for example if
you wanted to quantitate IGG you could
use either the protein a protein G or
protein l biosensors
or if you wanted to measure the kinetics
of antibody binding as I'm going to show
some examples of later in this webinar
and you could use the anti-iggfc capture
um biosensors or the ahc biosensors
or another one I'm going to show some
examples of which gives you a bit more
flexibility in terms of what proteins
you
immobilize onto the sensor you could use
some in the range of the strip
dividend-based biosensis and so
obviously this means you could
immobilize any biotin-tied protein that
you have in order to monitor the
interactions with other molecules
and then another example I'm going to
show later which isn't including this
list are from the glium and glass kits
so these contain everything you need
from protocol to buffers to the
biosensors in order to measure the
glycon content of
um either
of your protein of interest and so this
would be specifically Manos or salic
acid
and these are the antibodies that were
used to exemplify this workflow so we've
used three anti-her2 antibodies
the first is a trusteesma biosimilar so
this is an anti-hair to human igg-1
antibody with a variable region
targeting her2 via domain four
um then we've also had CAD Seiler so
this is an antibody drug conjugate which
is based on trusted user map
um with the real key difference compared
to trust US map being that it has um
mutations in its variable region to link
to that ADC payload which in this case
is um tanzine or dm1 and obviously
because this antibody is also based on
trustus map it's going to Target her to
Via that same region on domain four
and then finally we have the partition
of biosimilar so this is another
anti-hair 2 ig1 except with a different
variable region which targets a
different episode of her2 in domain two
and so we split the project up into a
multi-stage workflow determining
different
um characteristics about the antibodies
at each phase so in phase one we really
focus on The Binding of the antibody to
the antigen
and we did that on one hand by looking
at um binding to live cells using the IQ
platform and so doing this we could do
things like generate concentration
response Curves in order to compare
um relative ec50s of the antibodies
we could also include both antigen
positive and antigen negative target
cells in order to get an idea of the
antibody and specificity
we're then in parallel use the octet to
have a look at the kinetics of antigen
binding so this allowed us to
um measure the association dissociation
between the antibodies and soluble her2
protein and then the software could use
those association association rates to
generate KD values
next in phase two on the IQ we had a
look at the competition of binding so we
could get an idea of which antibodies
bound to the same or different epitopes
and then for phase two on the architect
we had started to have a look at
post-translational modification in the
form of that glycosylation using those
giamine glass kits that I introduced
earlier and so we can measure the
manners and sciatic acid content to get
an idea of the stupidity and also the FC
function of the antibodies
then on phase three on the IQ we took a
real deeper dive into the function of
the antibodies by looking at
um
using the cell based assays and the
associated IQ kits for measuring
antibody internalization ADCC adcp and
then also to explore that ADC activity
of the catsila
we then also looked at
um FC gamma receptor interactions on the
octet and so obviously this gives a good
indication of um potential FC function
so starting with the Ikea lifestyle
binding assay
so this is a really simple two-step
labeling assay where we started with
target cells so in this case that was
um highly her2 positive ae565 cells from
a breast cancer cell line
these were incubated with those
anti-her2 antibodies which were of
course unlabeled
and then they were secondly labeled with
a 404 conjugated antibody
and then we measured
the increase in medium fluorescence
intensity to give an indication of that
binding
um
expecting that with the ancientious on
the her2 positive selves to see an
increase in mfi with increased antibody
concentration
and the key thing about this assay is
that all the labeling steps were carried
out on Ice in order to inhibit any
internalization and to ensure that we
are really just looking at that surface
binding
and this is the kind of data that was
generated so this is a three four well
heat map pulled from the foresight
software
and so here we had
um
12 different concentrations per antibody
with three replicates at each
concentration
and you can see we had the um
an IGG control then we had our trust US
map akad Sila and patus map but as well
as the the sort of native forms of each
of those antibodies we did also include
um heated heated forms of the antibodies
so these had been heated at 69 degrees
Celsius for either 45 or 90 minutes and
we hope this would also give a bit of an
idea of the thermal stability of the
antibodies
um and in the heat map the darker gray
colors
um indicate a higher mfi so increased
antibody binding
and the real thing we could we could
pick out straight away from the heat map
was that
um for the trastusa map whether the it
was the native antibory or the heat
advantis the mfi each concentration was
was relatively
um similar
but if we compared the native catsila
and fatuzumab to the heated antibodies
you could see there was a graduated loss
in mfi at each concentration
um indicating that there was a reduced
potency binding upon heating of the
antibodies
and this is really just the same data in
as in the previous slide but pulled out
into concentration response curves and
also with those easy 50 values pulled
out below and really this just
highlights the um it confirmed what we
saw in the previous slide with the
trapezium of biosimilar having a fairly
constant ec50 value regardless of
whether it had been heated or it was the
native antibody
whereas with both the katsina and patus
map we saw a gradual increase in the
ec50 to indicate that reduced potency
binding up to about a two-fold loss in
binding potency by that 90 minute time
time Point compared to the the native
um and as I mentioned earlier we did
also use this to have a look at the
specificity so in those same Wells of
the plate and where we assessed
um antibody binding to the ae565 cells
we did also include
um her2 negative NDA mb468 cells and
we'd labeled those with the IQ Violet
encoder die and so that we could
distinguish them as as you can see in
this plot in the in the left from the
ae565s and then
um here in the bar chart you can see The
Binding of that top concentration of
antibody with those her2 positive and
her2 negative cells and it just showed
that clearly the antibodies were all
highly specific to the antigen positive
cell types
so next we had a look at that antigen
binding kinetics on the octet
so as I mentioned earlier we used the
ahc biosensors in order to measure this
so they come pre-mobilized with a
antibody that for FC capture of um human
human antibodies
and um this meant that we could capture
our
um human FC containing proteins so the
traffic or patusumab and that was in the
loading step and then we can measure
both the association and dissociation of
our analyte which in this case was the
soluble truncated form of the her2
protein
and it's just the sort of data that was
generated so
um we loaded a single concentration of
the antibody onto the biosensors so um
0.25 micrograms per ml and then we
measured the association of a range of
concentrations of that her2 protein
ranging from 50 down to 3.1 nanomolar
and the the trace you can see here see
here is a
um
overlay of three replicates
um per concentration fit with a
one-to-one binding model
and so obviously we repeated that for
um all three of the the anti-woodies
and then we pulled out the KD values
from the software
and what we saw was that the KD for the
trapeziuma biosimilar and the cadsila
were were pretty similar
um which was what we expected really
because obviously they both contain the
same variable region so really we're
measuring the same interaction between
the protein and the antibody
and but for the pertuzumab we did see
about a three-fold
um increased KD integrating a three-fold
lower affinity
and if we looked more closely at the
association and Association rates from
which those
um KD values were derived we could see
that really the the association rates
were pretty
um comparable between the three
antibodies but actually it was the and
threefold
um faster rate of dissociation of per
twozumab that was leading to that loss
in its um Affinity relative to the other
antibodies
and so then we went back and we wanted
to compare how those
um relative ec50s measured on the IQ
compared to the relative KDs measured on
the octet and so what we noticed is that
the the relative values on each
instrument were actually different so on
the IQ we saw fairly comparable
um
and and increase patiency binding with
trustees map and partus map and then it
was actually the cad China that had the
um lower uh level binding whereas with
the octet as I've just shown it was
obviously that pattus mob that had the
um lowest lowest affinity
and so I really really think this just
highlights that it can be really useful
to generate um
measurements for Target binding using a
couple of different platforms
um and the the instruments provide
complementary measurements that that
really provide
um lots of information about your
molecule of interest and so obviously on
one hand the IQ you're really getting an
indication of The Binding of that
um
antibody to the native Target as it is
on live cells but you're really also
relying on that secondary antibody
binding
um where I was on the octet
um obviously the focus is more on that
um molecular level interaction and the
association dissociation kinetics
um but then again we are also using a
solubilized and truncated form of that
her2 protein
so really yeah both instruments are
going to give
um some useful data to describe those
those molecules
so next we had a look at the um
competition binding using the IQ
so this assay
um a set up slightly differently to the
direct binding assay in that um we
started by taking a single concentration
of the
um anti-2 antibody and labeling with the
secondary antibody
then we mixed those with a range of
concentrations of unlabeled anti-hair 2
antibody
and then mixed with our target cells
and this meant that we were measuring a
decrease in mfi as to give an indication
of whether
um competition had occurred between that
labeled antibody and the unlabeled
antibody
and so this is the sort of data that was
generated for the anti-her2 antibodies
so you can see here we've got the
um
labeled a single concentration of the
labeled antibodies along the top here
um and then we've got a range of
concentrations of each of the antibodies
um along here so essentially we're
looking for a lighter gray color to
indicate that competition did occur in
those conditions
um
and what we saw was was as we expected
so the there was competition between the
trusteeismab and the catsila and
obviously as they bind to the the same
epitope that's that's what we expected
to see
uh but there was no competition between
those trapeziuma-based antibodies and
the pertuzumab
um since it binds to a different epitope
and obviously that
um highlights why it can be used as a
combination therapy um for example with
trastuzumab
so next we had a look at glycosylation
on the octet
so as I mentioned before we used the
glium and glass kit to measure the
mannose and cyclic acid content of the
anti-woodies and this was done using a
one-step direct binding assay
um so in this we could dilute all the
antibodies to single concentration
and then we could measure their binding
to these um
lectin pre-mobilized spirosensors which
will obviously bind to
um those specific glycans on the
antibodies and then we can measure
um a the relative level of glycosylation
between our antibodies
and this is the um data that was
generated for the anti-hertio antibodies
and so what we saw was that the
antibodies ranked in the same order for
both the Manos and silic acid content
with the patus map showing the greatest
level of glycosylation then the trust
you use map and then the cad scila
um and the reason we wanted to measure
this is because this the glycosylation
levels can link to things such as
stability and so for example we did
notice that obviously the trusteism of
the cad scila
um they are essentially the same
antibody apart from those mutations in
the FC region to include the um Linker
to the ADC payload in the in the
cadstyler and we did hypothesize that
perhaps the mutation to um include the
Linker may result in the loss of some
glycosylation sites and and what we did
see when we look back at the data from
our IQ binding essay was that actually
if you the um the catsila had much lower
thermal stability compared to the trash
use map antibody and so perhaps the um
loss in the glycosylation sites have
resulted in um lost thermal stability
although obviously this is going to
require some further exploration because
obviously the patus map didn't fit with
that um
with that theory showing both high level
glycosylation and
um sensitivity to the Heat denaturation
um also with the
um the glycoslation can indicate things
such as
um FC function but again I think this is
going to require some further
explanation and also a um larger sample
size in order to really start to uncover
links between these between these
metrics
so next we use a range of functional
assays to assess the entities using the
IQ
so first we used the
um IQ antibody internalization kit which
includes a pH sensitive probe which you
label the antibodies with and then you
can
measure the increase in mfi as the
internalized antibody with that
fluorescent probe starts to fluoresce as
the um probe enters the acidic endosomal
and lysosomal pathways
the kit also contains a membrane
Integrity die so you can exclude the
dead cells and then also an encoded eye
so
um similarly similar to as was done with
the um IQ binding assay you could
analyze binding to multiple cell types
in a in a single well in this case you
could measure internalization with
multiple cell types
and what we saw was that the antibodies
were barely comparable in terms of their
internalization
but what was notable was that the um
kadzilla actually had the
um lowest potency
um internalization with the highest ec50
um which obviously was interesting
because with the cutsyla being an ADC
um it's really the antibody that relies
on that internalization capacity and to
deliver that mechanism of action
and so because of that we we just wanted
to explore the um ADC activity of the
catsila using a really simple
um monoculture assay with the The ae565
Stills again
um this time incubated with a range of
concentrations of each of the antibodies
for 72 hours
and then we lifted the au565 cells from
the plate and analyzed them using a
membrane Integrity die to quantify the
level of cell death after that 72 hour
period
and what we saw was that um as we
expected only the catsila had
um induced cell death in that
monoculture and format over that time
period And so so confirmed that it did
have that unique ADC activity
next we wanted to have a look at the um
adcp activity of the antibodies and so
use the IQ
um adcp kit
so this relies on measuring the
um co-localization between your target
cells and phagocytic immune cells
um and so in this case we set up a
co-culture of
um pbmcs at 20 to 1 effective Target
ratio with the ae565s
the AE 5065s were labeled with the green
encoded eye from the um adcp kit
the dead cells were excluded using a
member Integrity die and then
um the
um phagocytic immune cells so monocytes
or macrophages were labeled using the
adcp detection reagent which labels
those cd14 positive effectors
and the kit also comes with a preset
gating template which is imported
directly into the software
um and that looks like this so
um
the gate for obviously the the entire
cell population
and then unique to this this kit
compared to some of our other kits we
don't include a singlet gate so that we
can um
ensure that we capture those
co-localization events
then we'll gate for the live cell
population and then within that we'll
get for our encoded targets and then
within that we'll get as well for the
cd14 positive
um phagocytic cells so that we've
um got a measure of those co-localized
targets and effectors
and this is what the data looked like
for our Angie how to antibodies so again
they were pretty comparable in terms of
their induction of adcp activity
um
but it was noticeable that the the
trusteeism map did have slightly
um increased potency compared to the
other two and about at about 2.5 fold
um increased
um a DCP activity
um so finally we had a look at the
um ADCC activity the antibodies using
the IQ NK killing kit
um so for this I say we co-cultured the
ae565 cells again with natural killer
cells
um and that was a five to one effect to
Target ratio
in this kit there is a violet encoded
eye to label the targets to distinguish
from the immune cells
again it contains a memory Integrity die
and then it also contains an antibody
cocktail and so this allows us to
um
phenotype the NK cells so the CD3 minus
cd56 positive population
we can then also measure the cd16
expression so that's obviously a strong
indicator of ADCC activity
and then we can also look at the NK
Activation so using markers cd69 and
cd25
and the kit also contains Q beads for
cytokine detection so this is a two-plex
screen containing
um interferon gamma and ground Zine B me
measuring cubes and so these are
obviously strong indicators of NK
activation and also NK killing
and this is the gating strategy provided
with the NK killing kit
so
um this it can be imported directly into
the software
um and is provided with the kit it also
comes with um
a preset compensation Matrix
um so obviously you don't have to
perform any commentation yourself which
is as
um drastically speeds up the time during
your asset development process
um and basically at the top here we've
got our um
cell um cell gating so from the cell
population through to getting our live
effectors and then distinguishing those
nks and then getting the um
activation markers on those nks
and then below here we've got our kiweed
gating to show how we distinguish the
interferon gamma and granzine B signals
usually
um for example if we're working with
suspension target cells we would
um Multiplex the analysis of the cells
and Beads
um and so distinguish all of this from
um a sample taken from a single well
the reason we've had to split this out
today to separately analyze the cells
and the um Supernatural cytokines is
because of the use of the adherent
target cells to those au565s and so
obviously we need to take a sample of
our supinating out and transfer that to
a separate plate before we can then
start to remove the media to lift the
au565 cells
um from the plate for for the downstream
and cell analysis
and so this is the data that was
generated for the ADCC activity so again
the antibodies look pretty comparable in
terms of the induction of cell death
but if we do look a bit more closely
down at the ec50 values to indicate the
the potency of the induction of cell
death we can see that actually there was
a slightly reduced potency
um with the the trastuzma biosimilar
um and the reason I call this out
despite it being quite a small
difference is that if we then have a
look at the
um
cd25 activation marker expression and
also the induction of interfering gamma
um so a cytokine indicative of
activation
um we can see that that both of those
were slightly reduced with the
trapeziuma by a similar relative to the
other two antibodies
um so you know particularly perhaps if
we looked at this over a Time course we
may have seen that these these effects
started to
um have an impact on the um
amount of killing
I haven't shown the data here but we the
um both the cd69 expression and the
grand Zone B release were both also
reduced
with the translucent map compared to the
other two antibodies
and then here we've also got the the
cd16 expression so that was fairly
comparable again between the three
antibodies with the decrease in cd16
expression indicating an increase in
ADCC activity
and here this slide just really
summarizes all of the the ec50 values
from each of those
um IQ cell-based functional assays that
I've just shown
um really just to highlight that
obviously each of the antibodies is
going to have a different potency of
effect in each of these
um
effective mechanisms and that it's going
to be obviously a combination of all of
these mechanisms that's going to induce
the overall tumor cell killing activity
in Vivo
um and that's why it's really useful to
use in vitro assay such as these in
order to to pull out the individual
activity in order to inform those later
later in Vivo studies
and then finally we had a look at the FC
gamma receptor to antibody interactions
and for these experiments we used a um
streptavidin mobilized biosensor and
this meant that we could immobilize a
biotinylated form of cd16a or FC Gamers
up to 3A protein
and then we could measure the kinetics
of binding with a range of
concentrations of our anti-her2
antibodies
and due to the nature of the binding
with the the cd16a protein in this case
we fit with a two to one heterogeneous
ligand binding model and this meant that
we generated two Association two
dissociation and two KD values
um per antibody for The Binding to cd16a
and so this is the data that was
generated
um so the the key thing we really picked
out is that both kd1 and kd2 for the
trastusma biosimilar were lower so
indicating
um increase affinity for the trustees
map to the FC gamma receptor
um when we look more closely at the
association and Association rates we can
see that um with kd-1 it was really a um
slower rate of dissociation that was
contributing to that enhanced Affinity
um whereas with the kd2 it seems to be
more a combination of um faster
Association and so a dissociation and
that was resulting in the the enhanced
Affinity there
and what we want to do is we want to
look further at this and we want to see
how the the
um FC gamma receptor binding May um
relate back to the ADCC activity and to
do this we really want to increase our
sample size and also get um some sort of
more more extremes of um
uh function and binding and so to do
this we're going to bring back the um
the heated antibodies that we use in the
early IQ experiments and this just shows
some some preliminary data and from that
so here is a single concentration of the
antibodies looking at their FC gamma
receptor binding and we can see that
there's a clear drop off
um gradual drop-off as well with the um
increased heat time compared to the um
Native cadsila
and we hope that this would obviously
relate back to
um a drop in ADCC activity and when we
measure back in the the IQ assay
so to conclude the IQ Advanced first
automata and octet bli label-free
analysis systems can be used in parallel
to broadly characterize antibodies and
to generate complementary data sets to
describe your antibodies of Interest
both platforms use streamlined and easy
to follow workflows which are coupled
with high throughput data acquisition
and provides a simple and Rapid solution
for antibody profiling
the techniques have the potential to
screen binding and functional
characteristics of libraries of
antibodies in minimal time and so this
delivers enhanced drug Discovery
processes
if you'd like any more information about
any of the assets you've seen in this
webinar please visit our website so
we've got
um web pages and application notes to
describe both the IQ and the octet
applications
thank you very much for listening I look
forward to answering your questions
the live q a portion of this webinar if
you have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in from our audience
our first question Kirsty as some of the
functional assays required the use of
primary immune cells is it likely that
there would be differences in response
between cell donors
um yeah so a lot of our work that we've
done particularly with the ADCC and adcp
assays have shown that there can be
quite a big difference between
um green cell donors in terms of the
level of response and so you might want
to try a couple of different donors
um but that being said typically
although the kind of maximal response
might differ metrics like the ec50 tend
to remain quite similar so it can be
fine when you're kind of trying to
compare different antibodies
thank you so much and could the octet FC
gamma receptor assay be used to measure
binding to other receptors aside from
cd16a
so since we were using
um this streptoberden immobilized
biosensors we could basically have
immobilized antibiotinylated protein
onto the sensor and obviously we'd have
to just carry out some further
optimization steps
um we could have also flipped the assay
and carried out in a more similar way to
the antigen binding assay and so instead
immobilizing the assay um a mobilizing
antibodies onto the ahc biosensors and
then measuring binding of
um soluble FC receptors
thank you so much and again I want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
would it be possible Christy to measure
the concentrations of more or different
cytokines and then if if in gamma and
grandime B using the ADCC assay
yeah so
um with the with the NK so um there are
some companion keeping kits so basically
you can just add a few extra
um beads into the wells and it means you
can
um directly measure other cytokines
alongside the interim gamma and the
grand Zone B
um or
um because the the volumes needed for
the kit are so low you would also have
um plenty of leftover soup and eating if
you wanted to kind of take 10 Margaritas
away and do a completely separate um
keyword analysis in a different place
thank you so much and it looks like we
have one more question coming in how
could you gather temporal data for the
IQ functional assays would that require
multiple plates to be set up
so if you're
um just using sort of like suspension
cells
um or or maybe in the the shorter term
adherence all assets where we don't
allow the cells to adhere to the plate
um because we don't leave them for long
enough then you could just take 10
microfit samples
um over time and we find this to be
non-determined to the assay
um but in in the case that you did want
to do kind of a longer term adherence
our assay where the cells have it here
adhere to the plate you're obviously
going to have to lift these off
um at the end point and so in this case
you would need to
um conduct analysis of multiple
identical players if you wanted to get
some temporal data
Christy I want to thank you for your
time today and your presentation would
you like to provide any closing remarks
for our audience before you go
um just thanks very much for listening
um I hope it's been insightful for you
well again I want to thank you for your
time and your important research and
before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsor Sartorius for
sponsoring today's webinar questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed for two years until
February 22nd
2025. Labyrinth will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye